[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm here with the young actor just
getting a start jabs at Ryan Romo
it's Ryan Rodney milds pop she's a name
that sounds like someone forgot my name
yes exactly what we are going to
recreate a scene from the movie The
Notebook which is both of our favorite
movie drew not so popular with women but
this is another men's flesh it's gonna
be fantastic and this is going on too
long but that's where the awkwardness
comes in yep
and that wave until we get to the next
wave which is also awkward and still
awkward no - Larry oh wait - no that's
right that's her and
[Music]
is in the movie they just he just like
comes in and kisses this will be my most
confusing erection of the day I promise
you the third yeah in the movie party
why someone needs to be off-camera
getting me lines because I'm normally
I'm really late stage Regan just that
first line okay I got it
alright let's turn the rate on
it's crystal the only is that for enemas
but all right this is your host animal
Kristoff
ex I'm Tony's wine you're right
what it wasn't over for me I waited for
you for seven years and now it's too
late
was it over for me
still is it over for me
oh yeah anyone six I think we guy right
[Music]
you